what's your favorite thing about playing
in st. Louis
yes it's actually my first time in USA
yeah of course I heard about this club
but I have never been to us before so
it's nice that in my first visited cell
fibers in the best club I'm always happy
to be in st. Louis I mean I've been
coming here every year for more than 10
years sometimes multiple times a year so
it's really like coming back home
it's very nice atmosphere here you feel
hot
well I think st. Louis is a chess center
for not only for America also in the
world I'm also very happy to be here the
best part is the conditions here we get
the best conditions so beat in every
single way and especially the place
where we play the club is so good and
the whole area in this place everything
I really love it st. Louis is just well
like a chess hub I guess everywhere you
go there's like chess you know like all
the restaurants here and there like
talking about the Karen's cup and stuff
and I think that's really nice I think
it's even stronger this year I'm really
happy to be part of it what I can say
for sure that I just fell in love with
st. Louis in 2011 with this place with
this club it's one of the few places
that I went just for tourist purposes
because I mean I told my husband about
this place and we just visited for a few
days we passed by I showed him the the
King plays the club D then when I found
out about Karen's cup and about this
tournament I was also very delighted and
very happy and when I got invited to the
first edition
we accepted it